vamos con el problema número 31 dice en
un club de costura están haciendo un
edredón que consiste de 25 cuadrados
cada uno de los cuales tiene de lado 30
centímetros entonces este es uno de los
cuadrados y cada uno de estos cuadrados
tiene el lado 30 centímetros entonces
cada uno de sus lados mide 30
centímetros ok si el edredón tiene 5
filas y 5 columnas de cuadrados
cuál es el perímetro del edredón ok
entonces el edredón como son 5 filas y 5
columnas pues también va a ser un
cuadrado un cuadrado hecho por 5 filas y
5 columnas de cuadrados entonces ahí van
las 5 columnas 5 bueno no van a quedar
muy cuadrados pero espero que se vea la
idea
entonces imaginemos que todos esos de
ahí son cuadrados y 55 filas
entonces es de 5 x 5 cuadrados y cada
cuadrado tiene 30 centímetros de 30
centímetros y lo que es lo que nos
preguntan es el perímetro del edredón
entonces tenemos que determinar el lado
del edredón para empezar y como el lado
está hecho por cinco pequeños lados de
30 centímetros entonces este lado es de
150 centímetros
y por lo tanto todos los lados son de
150 centímetros 150 150 y 150 y entonces
el perímetro del edredón es 4% 50 o sea
600 600 la opción c muy bien siguiente
problema problema número 32 a este se ve
bien padre a ver qué dice los cuatro
lados de esta figura ésta de aquí se van
a doblar hacia arriba para hacer una
caja abierta o sea vamos a doblar la
figura por aquí por acá por acá
y por acá y al doblar cada uno de estos
lados pues se hace una caja verdad baja
entonces éstos los doblamos para arriba
para arriba y para arriba y dice para
hacer una caja abierta la pregunta es
cuál será el volumen de la caja bueno
pues la caja más o menos nos quedaría
algo así esta base que puse quedaría
como base aquí más o menos algo así ahí
quedaría la base entonces pues tenemos
que ver cuál es cada uno de estos lados
verdad porque para encontrar el volumen
necesitamos multiplicar largo por ancho
por alto entonces es 1 2 3 4 5 5
centímetros 5 centímetros aquí aquí
también son 5 5
5 centímetros y tenemos que ver ahora
cuánto queda de alto entonces esta de
aquí apenas es la base pero al doblar
este nos queda más o menos algo así
cierto más o menos algo de este estilo
aquí queda partido a la mitad con 1 2 3
4 5 del lado de manera similar al doblar
este nos queda por acá al doblar el otro
nos queda por acá y al doblar el último
nos queda por allá y entonces nos queda
que la altura de esta caja es 2
de esta forma bueno 2 centímetros de
esta forma tiene 5 de largo 5 de ancho y
2 de alto y por lo tanto su volumen es 5
por 5 25 por 250 entonces sería la
opción está muy bien la opción a
problema número 33 un globo terráqueo
tiene 18 pulgadas de diámetro entonces
aquí está nuestro globo terráqueo que
está bien bonito y el diámetro el
diámetro es de 18 pulgadas vamos a
ponerle 18 y sale cuál de las siguientes
opciones es la mejor aproximación en
pulgadas cuadradas para el área de su
superficie hay aquí nos dicen cuál es la
fórmula el área de la superficie está
dada por cuatro por y por radio al
cuadrado bueno no tenemos el radio
todavía tenemos el diámetro pero el
radio es simplemente la mitad el radio
es la mitad
entonces el radio sería 9 pulgadas 9
pulgadas y así el área de la superficie
el área de la superficie estaría dada
por 4 por ti por pi por el radio que es
9 al cuadrado o sea sería 4 por 81 por
pi
por ti y esto cuánto y saber 4 por 81 es
324 324 multiplicado x pi
entonces nos quedaría pues pies como
3.14 entonces pues es más de 33 por 324
pues es 900 y tanto como 960 pero el
punto 14 va a hacer que se acerque mucho
a 1000 entonces pues debería hacer algo
al menos mayor que 900 y de estas
opciones de la única que es mayor que
900 es estar acá la de y seguramente
debe estar muy cercano el valor del área
a este de aquí entonces vamos a elegir
la respuesta de muy bien siguiente
problema problema número 34 34 dice el
rectángulo que se muestra tiene base de
20 metros y altura de 10 metros le voy a
poner que esto es 20 y que esto es 10 me
puse 20 acá y no del otro lado porque
parece ser que este lado es más largo
entonces pues más o menos esto nos ayuda
a visualizarlo un poco mejor pero bueno
vamos a ver qué quieren de este
rectángulo
si los cuatro triángulos que se muestran
se quitan del rectángulo este este este
y este cual será el área de la figura
que queda
bueno pues cuál es el área inicial del
rectángulo antes de quitar cualquier
cosa pues es 20 por 10 o sea 200 200 muy
bien pero ahora lo que queremos quitar
son las áreas de estos cuatro
triangulitos basta encontrar el área de
uno de esos y los demás van a tener la
misma área entonces digamos tomemos el
de aquí hay que hacer este base por
altura entre dos es importante dividir
entre dos porque si no nada más estamos
calculando el área de este rectángulo
entre dos ya es el triángulo entonces
sería 4x4 16 entre 2 es 8 entonces este
triangulito tiene voy a poner otro color
más fuerte y ese triangulito tiene tiene
área 8 éste tiene área 8 área 8 área 8
entonces a estos 200 iniciales tenemos
que restar cuatro veces 8 ya tenemos que
restar 32 y por lo tanto el área que
queda es 200 menos 32 que es ciento
68 y todo esté en metros verdad entonces
168 metros cuadrados que es la opción c
muy bien finalmente vamos a este
problema al 35 al 35 después continuamos
con otros por aquí está el 36 pero vamos
a terminar este vídeo con este problema
que dicen 7 w es un rombo cuál es el
área de w x del triángulo w x t ok
entonces rctv w
quiere decir que sus cuatro lados miden
lo mismo y estoy aquí mide 12 entonces
todos miden 12 12 y 12 entonces supongo
que quieren que juguemos un poco con la
figura para determinar el área entonces
vamos a hacer algunas cosas por ejemplo
el triángulo r w es un triángulo
isósceles porque este lado r w es el
mismo que este de acá es el mismo que
estoy acá mide 12 los dos mil en 12 y
entonces si este ángulo mide 60 grados
este ángulo de acá también va a medir 60
grados 60 grados pero observa el
triángulo r w ya tiene dos ángulos
60 grados entonces el tercero también
tiene que ser de 60 grados también tiene
que ser de 60 grados y por lo tanto el
triángulo r w es un triángulo equilátero
y así rt rt también mide 12 entonces srt
rt el segmento de rete mide 12 muy bien
entonces ya que tenemos eso ahora
podemos utilizar otra propiedad esta es
otra cosa interesante que sucede en los
rombos en los rombos las diagonales son
perpendiculares y se cortan a la mitad
entonces ahí son perpendiculares y se
cortan a la mitad si este es 12 de r a
este punto mide 6 de este punto acá mide
6 y con esto
6 y con esto llamamos muy avanzados en
el problema tenemos que v w x t es un
triángulo rectángulo donde ya conocemos
la hipotenusa y uno de los catetos
entonces podemos utilizar el teorema de
pitágoras para encontrar v w x y déjame
ponerle a ese lado x entonces tendríamos
que x al cuadrado más 6 al cuadrado es
igual a la hipotenusa al cuadrado es
igual a 12 al cuadrado entonces x al
cuadrado es igual a 144 menos 36 x al
cuadrado es igual a 108-108 entonces x
es igual a raíz de 108 raíz de 108 y me
parece que este radical se puede
simplificar un poco porque 108 es igual
a 9 por 12
9 x 12 108 ajá y esto es igual a 9 por 4
por 3 nada más el 12 lo puse como 4 por
así x es igual a raíz de 9 por 4 por 3
que es igual a raíz de 9 por raíz de 4
por raíz de 3 que es igual a entonces x
es igual a raíz de 93 raíz de 4 es 23
por 12 6 entonces x es igual a 6 raíz de
36 raíz de 3 y con esto pues ya vamos
súper súper bien porque tenemos la
medida de x es 6 raíces de 3 y entonces
ya tenemos la base y la altura del
triángulo w x de el triángulo w x te
dejan de marcarlo
con otro color
si no no se ve nada entonces ya tenemos
su base y su altura entonces el área
simplemente sería le voy a poner así el
área sería igual a un medio por 6 por 6
raíz de 3 vamos a ver cuánto es esto
6 entre 12 es 3 3 por 6 618 así que nos
queda igual a 18 raíz de 3 muy bien 18
raíz de 3 vamos a ver si está por aquí
si la la a esta opción 18 raíz de 3 y
por lo tanto la respuesta de éste es 18
raíz de 3 muy bien vamos a dejarle hasta
aquí le seguimos en el próximo vídeo